jetzt wie gesagt dass der neue
tagesordnungspunkt kinder jugend
stärkung gesetz und erste rednerin ist
karl marx die parlamentarische
staatssekretärin im bundesministerium
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
und sie ist von der spd
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen heute
beraten wir abschließend in zweiter und
dritter lesung eine große und wichtige
reformen des achten sozialgesetzbuchs
das kinder und jugend stärkung gesetz
darüber freue ich mich sehr denn ich
habe dieses gesetz auf seinem langen weg
von anfang an begleitet mit dieser
komplexen reform stärken wir kinder
jugendliche und familien in unserem land
spürbar und auch langfristig wir öffnen
für sie neue chancen und perspektiven
wir stärken aber auch die vielen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in der
breit aufgestellten kinder und
jugendhilfe und wir verzahnen akteure an
zentralen schnittstellen miteinander so
gelingt zum beispiel ein noch besserer
kinderschutz im
bundesfamilienministerium haben wir
gemeinsam mit den koalitionsfraktionen
entschieden uns ausreichend zeit für
diese umfangreiche angelegte reform zu
nehmen und das ergebnis gibt uns recht
die vielen verbesserungen die der
gesetzentwurf für die kinder und
jugendhilfe schafft lassen sich in fünf
zentrale bereiche einteilen
ein besserer kinder und jugendschutz die
stärkung von kindern und jugendlichen in
pflegefamilien und einrichtungen der
erziehungshilfe hilfen aus einer hand
für kinder und jugendliche mit und ohne
behinderungen mehr prävention vor ort
und mehr beteiligung
von jungen menschen eltern und familien
die bedürfnisse der kinder und
jugendlichen stehen dabei ganz besonders
im vordergrund ganz im sinne der un
kinderrechtskonvention und der
gesetzentwurf hat ferner im blick dass
entscheidungen für kinder jugendliche
und eltern nachvollziehbar sein müssen
und es gibt erstmals ein
beschwerdemanagement über die
ombudsstellen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in der letzten
legislaturperiode wurde unsere kinder
und jugendhilfe reform leider nicht
abschließend im bundestag beraten
für den zweiten anlauf unseres kinder
und so gut stärkung des gesetzes haben
wir uns entschieden einen breiten
beteiligungsprozess vorzuschalten der
dialog prozess mitreden mitgestalten die
zukunft der kinder und jugendhilfe war
über ein jahr angelegt beteiligt waren
expertinnen und experten aus
wissenschaft und praxis der kinder und
jugendhilfe der behindertenhilfe der
gesundheitshilfe sowie vertreter aus
bund ländern und kommunen über 70
personen haben zur thematischen
schwerpunkten miteinander diskutiert
sich eingebracht und gemeinsam mit uns
im ministerium um die wirklich besten
reformansätze gerungen und weitere
akteure konnten sich schriftlich
beteiligen
ideen liefern und kritisch in foren
mitmischen
unglaublich viel expertise ist in unsere
kinder und jugend stärken das gesetz
eingeflossen
ich durfte diesen dialog prozess leiten
und ich möchte mich an dieser stelle
nochmal ausdrücklich bei allen
beteiligten ganz herzlich bedanken
und ich kann sagen dieser prozess hat
sich wirklich gelohnt
er war von sehr fachlichen und auch
konstruktiven beratungen geprägt und
mein dank gilt auch den
koalitionsfraktionen für die guten und
konstruktiven gespräche im
parlamentarischen verfahren und
namentlich erwähnen möchte ich die
berichterstatterin ulrike bahr
für die spd-fraktion sowie den
berichterstatter markus weinberg für die
cdu/csu-fraktion liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen heute schließen wir unsere
gemeinsamen beratung ab das ist wirklich
ein riesiger erfolg über den wir uns
auch wirklich gemeinsam freuen können
herzlichen dank so rott caren marks die
stellvertretende parlamentarische
staatssekretärin des bundesministeriums
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
es geht um das kinder und jugend
stärkung des gesetz ein gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung der heute
verabschiedet wird da geht es zum
beispiel um die zusammenarbeit von
jugendamt oder jugendgericht
familiengericht und
strafverfolgungsbehörden und lehrerinnen
und lehrern das soll verbessert werden
redner der afg ist jetzt johannes huber
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend und auch in der
kinderkommission ist er mitglied und
meine damen und herren die
bundesregierung liegt uns heute einen
gesetzentwurf vor der sich für uns wie
ein flickenteppich durch das sgb acht
zieht sie springen von der senkung der
kosten beteiligung von kindern und
jugendlichen an ihrer eigenen
stationären unterbringung über die
stärkung so genannter selbst
vertretungen von leistungsberechtigten
die implementierung eines verfahrens
lotsen der das von ihnen verursachte
chaos eine übergangszeit für betroffene
erträglicher machen soll
bis hin zu ihrem lieblings thema
inklusion was einem gesetz aspekte
vorhandene
die auch wir begrüßen wie etwa die
verbesserten weil unangekündigten
kontrollen von einrichtungen der kinder
und jugendhilfe aber in der summe kann
man bilanzieren dass es sich noch
stärker auf den inhalt staat auf einen
schönen namen des gesetzes hätten
konzentrieren sollen
natürlich sind selbstvertretung ein ganz
entscheidender baustein wenn es darum
geht fehler und mängel im system zu
erkennen
so haben wir vor kurzem in der
kinderkommission durch den vorsitzenden
des landes heim rates hessen erfahren
müssen dass fremde untergebrachte kinder
und jugendliche keinen ausreichenden
wlan-zugang oftmals haben um in dem von
ihnen verhängten distanz unterricht
überhaupt bestehen zu können
von den geräten selbst holen wir gar
nicht erst sprechen aber es sollten dann
auch echte selbst vertretungen seien und
so empfinden wir es als wenig hilfreich
dass sie jenen ehrenamtlich tätige in
der kinder und jugendhilfe bei stellen
hier entsteht für uns der schale
eindruck dass sie letztlich eine
gefilterte meinung hören wollen die von
diesen aufpassen kontrolliert wird auch
die von ihnen eingeführten
vertrauenspersonen bieten die gefahr
dass sie die missstände er decken als
aufdecken was sich in der ersten lesung
schon ausgeführt habe ähnlich
inkonsequent verhalten sie sich auch bei
der senkung der kosten beteiligung von
kindern und jugendlichen in
vollstationären maßnahmen so haben sie
endlich erkannt dass es skandalös ist
das vermögen oder das duo harte arbeit
erarbeitete minijobs aufgebesserte
taschengeld für die mitfinanzierung der
einrichtungen einzuziehen
aber anstatt diesen missstand endlich
aus der welt zu schaffen
möchten sie auch in zukunft noch 25
prozent der einnahmen heranziehen
wie demotivierend muss es für einen
jungen menschen sein der unter
schwierigsten umständen aufwächst wenn
wir seine ersten schritte in ein
selbstbestimmtes leben auch noch eine
gebühr erhoben wird eine gebühr für
einen maßnahme die es sich nicht selber
ausgesucht hat sondern die vielmehr
ausdruck ist für dessen missliche lage
verabschieden sie sich alte von dieser
sondersteuer und geben sie diesen jungen
leuten die luft zum atmen
denn damit würden sie ihnen vermitteln
dass sie im leben etwas erreichen können
und bestrafen dass er sie bitte nicht
für die umstände in denen zu geben
müssen
geben sie auch jungen menschen eine
chance die aufgrund einer schweren
behinderung einen besonders holprigen
start in das leben hatten ihr ewiges
märchen von der undifferenzierten
inklusion scheitert nämlich an der
harten realität
sie erreichen nichts wenn sie nicht auf
die bedürfnisse der einzelnen eingehen
und diese in den mittelpunkt stellen
sondern diese menschen in generali
sierte projekte stellen sie erreichen
auch nichts wenn sie jeden betroffenen
jetzt einen betreuer zur seite stellen
denn erstens wissen sie selbst dass sie
nicht ausreichend personal haben und
zweitens sind diese leute auch nicht in
dem umfang qualifiziert wie echte
spezialisten die tagtäglich mit diesen
fällen zu tun haben
sie rauben daher eine ganze generation
junger menschen mit schwerer behinderung
die chance auch wenn möglichst
selbstbestimmtes leben und stellen ihre
ideologie leider über deren zukunft
aus diesem grund können wie ihren
gesetzentwurf heute nicht zustimmen
denn dafür hätten sie ein kinder und
jugend stärkung gesetz vorlegen müssen
dessen inhalt auch verspricht dessen
inhalt auch trägt was der name
verspricht vielen dank
johannes huber von der haben sich die
waffe angesprochen hat die kosten
beteiligen da geht es um die
kostenbeteiligung der menschen die sich
in stationären einrichtungen der kinder
und jugendhilfe oder in pflegefamilien
befinden 75 prozent ihres einkommens
mussten sie dafür bisher auffälligen das
soll jetzt obduziert werden
auch 25 prozent durch das gesetz und
vermögen wird dabei nicht herangezogen
nächster redner an und marcus weinberg
von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion zu
mir was hast du für den schicken anzug
ich habe immer schicker an zugang aber
heute habe ich an besonders schnieken
anzug weil es ein anlass für dieses
vorhaben gibt es ein tolles gesetz gibt
ein wichtiges gesetz und da haben wir
alle glaube ich mit beigetragen und der
sich ein herzliches dankeschön an alle
die dieses bewegt haben eine marke
kinder und jugendhilfe ja nicht immer
das große thema der öffentlichkeit sagen
in den medien oder ob fraktionssitzung
aber richtig ist es geht um tausende es
geht um zehntausende von kindern von
jugendlichen von familien die
benachteiligt sind
das sind diejenigen die unter keinen
positiven lebensbedingungen aufwachsen
und das sind diejenigen die gefahr
laufen von der sozialen und kulturellen
teilhabe abgehängt zu werden ist unsere
aufgabe sich um diese kinder zu kümmern
in chancengerechtigkeit zu geben
gesellschaftliche teilhabe und nach 30
jahren reformieren wie eines der
wichtigsten gesetze dieses landes ein
ganzes sozialgesetzbuch einer intensiven
diskussion und die wurde breit
aufgestellt und der dank von marx möchte
ich ausdrücklich ihnen zurückgeben und
für dieses engagement für die breite
diskussion am ende sehen sie heute was
es bringt wenn man einen transparenten
prozess entwickelt und gemeinschaftlich
mit allen dieses zusammen gestaltet und
ist ein großer erfolg deswegen immer
dankeschön auch dankeschön an frau waren
hendrix von der spd für die gute
zusammenarbeit
denn es geht um die kooperation im
kinderschutz es geht darum leicht
zugängliche
alltagshilfen mit unterstützungsbedarf
bereitzustellen um die implementierung
von ombudsstellen es geht um die
stärkere berücksichtigung von kindern
und pflegekindern und wenn ich das
zusammenfassen dafür uns im wesentlichen
wenn man fünf sätze hat um ein gesetz
zusammenzufassen
dann laufen diese fünf sätze relativ
einfach wir schaffen einen besseren
kinder und jugendschutz
wir stärken kinder und jugendliche in
pflegefamilien und in den einrichtungen
der erziehungshilfe wir bereiten die
hilfen aus einer hand für kinder und
jugendliche mit und ohne behinderung vor
wir sorgen für mehr prävention vor ort
und wir sorgen für mehr beteiligung von
jungen menschen und ihren familien dass
der kinder jugendliche und familien in
diesem land und deswegen bieten wir
unterstützung für dieses gesetz besseren
kinder und jugendschutz eine verbesserte
kooperation im kinderschutz durch die
stärkere einbeziehung des
gesundheitswesens in die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft für einen
wirksamen kinderschutz wir haben dann im
änderungsantrag und er liegt ihnen vor
und jetzt viele punkte aufgegriffen ich
möchte nur zwei drei exemplarische
nennen haben wir nochmal gesagt auch
ärztinnen und ärzte auch ärztinnen ärzte
sowie angehörige anderer heilberufe
sollen bei einer dringenden gefahr für
das kindeswohl im regelfall das
jugendamt informieren darauf kommt es
anders seine erfahrung der letzten jahre
gewesen
wir brauchen dringend kinder ärzte und
ärztinnen dafür dass wir fischte oder
bei der frage ob er feststellen können
dass das kindeswohl gefährdet ist und
wir wollen dann auch im
entschließungsantrag können sie das
nachlesen die konkretisierung der
leitlinien das die entwickelt werden
zweiter punkt stärke von kindern und
jugendlichen in pflegefamilien und
einrichtung der erziehungshilfe jahr 25
prozent des einkommens müssen dann in
anführungszeichen das einkommen wird um
25 prozent reduziert wir tragen ja auch
die kosten einer unterbringung wie ein
änderungsantrag noch mal aufgenommen
dass wir sagen 150 euro als freibetrag
für einkommen aus schülerjobs aus
praktika oder aus einer
ausbildungsvergütung und das glaube ich
ist auch ein deutlicher hinweis
das hier ferienjob und übrigens auch
ehrenamtliches engagement auch
unterstützen denn auch das ist
ausgenommen
das ist uns wichtig dass genau diese
jugendlichen gerade diesen jugendlichen
sich am ehrenamt engagieren
hilfe aus einer hand ja da wird der
schritt jetzt hat wirklich aufgenommen
verbindlich aufgenommen das ist ein
thema der nächsten jahre und es wird
noch viele diskussionen die platten hier
im deutschen bundestag beschäftigen wir
haben noch mal klassische dem
änderungsantrag und das war glaube ich
auch ein gutes einvernehmen dass wir
gesagt haben dass sinnvolle instrument
der verfahrens lotsen kann auch schon
vor dem ersten januar 2024 eingesetzt
werden wenn die voraussetzungen stimmen
wir stärken mehr prävention verordnung
da habe ich einen wichtigen punkt war
ich paul lehrieder sehen der auch mit
vielen anderen kolleginnen und kollegen
aller fraktionen dafür gekämpft hat für
das thema kinder psychisch kranker
eltern
wir schaffen es jetzt dass die kinder
und das sind nicht wenige sind 10.000
von kindern es 100.000 von kindern die
im jungen alter sich um die familie
kümmern müssen beide eltern suchtkrank
sind dass wir dort auch verbindlich
geschaffen dass die einen anspruch auf
eine regelleistung haben das ist ein
ergebnis nach jahren der guten
diskussion das ist uns besonders wichtig
dass diese familien gestärkt wenn dass
diese kinder gestört werden und dazu
kommt auch das thema § 19 sogenannte
gemeinsame wohnformen dass wir
erschaffen das die bindung zwischen den
eltern zwischen beiden elternteilen und
den kindern gestärkt werden
auch die fragestellung wie man die
unterbringung zusammenführen kann und
ein letzter punkt da muss man leider
schon schließen auch wenn es im norm
wenn es gewisse dinge gibt die nicht im
neuen text auftauchen sie sind wichtig
für uns das thema straßenkinder und
obdachlosigkeit da haben wir auch eine
anhörung gab das ist auch eine fraktion
zu verdanken dass sie diese anhörung auf
den weg gebracht hat wir sagen ganz
deutlich im entschließungsantrag das
wird ein thema sein das ist ein thema
für die nächsten jahre wir wollen
modellprojekte stärken insoweit herr
präsident komme ich zum schluss und sage
wirklich bitte unterstützen sie dieses
gesetz ist wichtig für die kinder für
die jugendlichen es ist ein gutes gesetz
und die große hoffnung ist auch dass der
bundesrat bittet dann auch diese
gesetzt in seiner verantwortung
unterstützt dass wir sagen können am
ende dieser legislaturperiode ein großer
erfolg für die familien für die kinder
und jugendlichen das wünschen wir uns
vielen dank für die gute zusammenarbeit
und wir bitten um zustimmung
soweit marke so ein tag in der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion zum kinde juden und
kinder und jugend stärkung des gesetzes
geht es ja um kinder wie es heißt mit
belastenden lebensumständen ein aspekt
ist übrigens auch das jetzt stellen
eingerichtet werden da können sich
eltern und kindern dann hinwenden bei
beschwert über entscheidungen von nun
wirklich dieser kinder mit belastenden
lebensumständen
nächster redner ist daniel schütz von
der fdp ausschuss für familie senioren
frauen und jugend
sehr geehrter herr präsident werte
kolleginnen und kollegen
was ist das für ein signal dass sie von
der kooi senden damit meine ich nicht
dass sich kollege weinberg so sehr
erfreut über seinen anzug sondern sie
machen 30 minuten debatte über die
größte reform sgb 830 minuten debatte
über die reform des sgb 8 erst am
donnerstagabend kamen 118
änderungsanträge der kokon jetzt wird
das hier durchgepeitscht das wird dem
thema nicht gerecht und es zeigt wieder
einmal wie cdu csu und spd die debatten
im deutschen bundestag wertschätzen
werte
kolleginnen und kollegen verstehen sie
mich nicht falsch
vieles an diesem gesetzentwurf ist
endlich ist innerlich gut aber gut
reicht manchmal einfach nicht aus also
zwei gleich zwei gleich es ist nur
schwer mit den gesichts und modularen
abdeckung die kolleginnen und kollegen
alle zu erkennen ich hab das wort zu
einer zwischen kollege fürst vielen dank
dass sie die zwischenfrage zu lassen
sie haben gerade die
koalitionsfraktionen dafür kritisiert
dass wir für ein so gewichtiges thema
nur eine 30 minuten debatte haben
darum möchte ich sie gerne fragen was
sie davon halten dass die fdp-fraktion
für die heutige kernzeit eine
einstündige debatte zum thema digitaler
impfpass angesetzt hat wo wir uns fragen
warum man für ein solches thema wo
bereits der europäische impfpass auf dem
weg ist eine einstündige debatte in der
kernzeit ansätze zur wertigkeit kollegen
jetzt völlig konsterniert ich habe jetzt
gedacht sie erklären mir das dass sie
das alles drüber gemacht haben mit den
kinder jugend stärken gesetz was de
facto ja falsch ist aber sie werfen uns
jetzt vor dass wir eine debatte auf
setzen die die menschen da draußen
bewegt genauso mit dieser debatte die
menschen bewegt wir wollen
dass es ist fällt ihnen das nicht auf
der gds für die cdu/csu dass wir im
kampf gegen korona anfangen die menschen
zu verlieren und wenn wir die menschen
verlieren im kampf gegen korona
verlieren wir den kampf gegen korona und
dann uns dort bin ich echt installiert
und dann vorzuwerfen dass wir über das
was millionen geimpfter übrigens auch
schon millionen genesener oben treiben
zur debatte im deutschen bundestag
machen
da war ich jetzt konstruiert überrascht
und ich teile ihre meinung in keiner
weise genau solche themen müssen wir
diskutieren
aber kommen wir kommen wir zum
gesetzentwurf zurück inhaltlich gut aber
gut reicht manchmal halt nicht aus wir
können ja davon ausgehen dass nach
dieser reform es ja doch jahre wenn
nicht sogar jahrzehnte dauert wird bis
wir wieder darüber reden
deswegen wäre es mir lieber wäre es uns
lieber von der fdp dafür stadt gut es
lieber exzellent machen bundes geht hier
um viele menschen es geht um viele
menschen die in diesem bereich arbeiten
es geht vor allen dingen aber um kinder
jugendlichen und familien und da müssen
wir insbesondere bei änderungen am
kinder- und jugendschutz genau
hinterfragen erreicht man das was man in
der theorie will auch in der praxis
einiges ist gut aber es sind auch
richtig böcke drin weil gut gemeint ist
nicht gleich gut gemacht ich habe wir
haben einige änderungsanträge
eingebracht wir wollen dass diese
reformen nicht nur gute exzellenz
wirklich kann aufgrund dieser turbo zeit
nicht auf alle änderungsanträge eingehen
deswegen die sachen die uns am
wichtigsten sind erstens der hilfeplan
des jugendamts bewährt und geschätzt in
der praxis basiert auf vertrauen und
wenn dieser hilfeplan jetzt an das
familiengericht weitergegeben kann dann
wird seine wirkung in der praxis
nachlassen dann wird das vertrauen in
diesen hilfeplan ausgehöhlt zweitens
ombudsstellen als baustein im ksg die
beteiligung von jungen menschen eltern
und familien zu verbessern ist ein sehr
gutes ziehen
aber diese ombudsstellen die müssen auch
wirklich unabhängig und dezentral
organisiert sein
unserer meinung nach darf eine
ombudsstelle niemals am jugendamt
eingesetzt seien nicht einmal im
gleichen den gleichen gebäude sein
drittens modellregionen und projekte die
inklusive umsetzung der kinder
jugendhilfe ist absolut richtig großes
ziel großes g8 ev absolut richtig aber
es ist komplex weil zwei
unterschiedliche systematiken
zusammengeführt werden
warum warten wir bis 2024 bzw 20 28
es gibt genügend kommunen und träger die
jetzt schon ideen und pläne in der
schublade haben die jetzt haben gern
staaten würden
geben wir ihnen doch die möglichkeiten
mit mit david modellregionen um
modellprojekten voranzugehen bei der
flächendeckenden ausführung bei der
flächendeckenden einführung wird uns
diese praxis erfahrung dann sehr sehr
helfen
liebe kollegen gut gemeint ist nicht
immer gut gemacht wir wollen aus guten
exzellent werden lassen
stimmen sie unsere änderungsanträge zu
die kinder und jugendhilfe hat es
verdient
vielen dank so war daniel pfister fdp
mit diesem appell ich erwähne vielleicht
noch ein punkt in dem neuen
gesetzentwurf zum kinder und jugend
stärkung des gesetzes sollen kinder und
jugendliche auch gegenüber dem jugendamt
an ihren eigenen medien gegenüber dem
jugendamt an den eigenen beratungs
anspruch bekommen ohne dass die eigenen
eltern davon erfahren das ist
möglicherweise ganz sinnvoll wenn sie
suchtkrank sind also jedenfalls haben
sie diese diskussion gegenüber ihren
eigenen eltern in diesem gesetzentwurf
netzen extra riethmüller von der
fraktion die linke
die koalition verspricht mit dem heute
vorgelegten gehen der jugend stärkung
gesetz eine umfassende reform der kinder
und jugendhilfe und tatsächlich und da
sagen wir auch als fraktion die linke
eine umfassende reform reformbedarf in
der kinder und jugendhilfe
die hätte es tatsächlich gegeben
denken wir an die völlig überlasteten
jugendämter wir haben gerade in berlin
aber auch allen anderen jugendämtern
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die bis
an die belastungsgrenze arbeiten die
häufig für 100 150 oder mehr familien
zuständig sind denen sie helfen sollen
und wo sie nur noch nach aktenlage
entscheiden können wir haben wir haben
erst vor zwei jahren eine studie
vorgelegt bekommen dass allein im
allgemeinen sozialen dienst also in den
jugendämtern 16.000 stellen fehlen
16.000 stellen die wir gerade bräuchte
der kinder und jugendhilfe und deswegen
haben wir als linke heute einen antrag
vorgelegt die wir die fachkräfte
situation verbessern können dazu
schweigt die koalition sich aus zweitens
wir müssen über care lieber reden auch
das ein großes thema der letzten jahre
wo sie nicht vorankommen wer lieber das
heißt junge menschen die aus den
stationären einrichtung der kinder- und
jugendhilfe kommen die im allerbesten
fall in die eigenständigkeit entlassen
werden aber nicht im regelfall im
regelfall werden sie entlassen hat sich
jesus thema und im schlechtesten fall in
die obdachlosigkeit der kollege beim rk
das angedeutet aber dann tun sie doch
was dann stärken sie die rechtsstellung
vom kern liefern
verbessern sie die rechtsansprüche für
junge volljährige damit sie nicht am
achtzehnten geburtstag vor die tür
gesetzt werden
wir müssen reden über eine bessere
ausstattung der jugendverbände das steht
seit 32 30 jahren im sozialgesetzbuch
acht drin jugendverbände sind zu fördern
aber das am ende völlig unverbindlich
reden sie doch mit den kämmerern vor ort
in kreisen die sagen ja das steht da
drin aber es gibt keinen richtigen
rechtsanspruch machen wir nicht fällt
aus gibt die kassenlage nicht im zweifel
kommt die kommunalaufsicht und sagt ist
eine freiwillige leistung fällt aus das
sind genau punkte hätten wie sie stärken
müssen darlegen sie nichts vorhabe und
stattdessen schlagen sie vor
im wesentlichen ein paradigmenwechsel in
der kinder und jugendhilfe und das will
ich an zwei beispielen kurz darstellen
sie feiern sich für einen gestärkten
kinderschutz ich teile das ausdrücklich
nicht kinderschutz in deutschland
basiert auf vertrauen und kooperation
wir wollen familien helfen ja kinder in
familien wo sie nicht bleiben können
müssen raus genommen
aber der erste ansatz ist familien zu
helfen und die kinder zu stärken was sie
mit den meldepflichten für ärzte jetzt
tun ist das ganze gegenteil was
passierte mit einer familie deren kinder
nicht gut geht gehen die jetzt häufiger
zum arzt wenn sie wissen dass diese
daten möglicherweise beim jugendamt
landen gehen sie jetzt häufiger zum arzt
nein die werden vielleicht häufiger
umziehen damit sie sich den untersuchung
besser entziehen können gern nicht
häufiger zum arzt kommen was sie hier
vorschlagen trinkt nicht mehr
kinderschutz das bringt weniger
klimaschutz und über 10
fachgesellschaften in der jugendhilfe im
prinzip die komplett geschlossene
fachwelt hat vor diesem weg gewarnt und
sie gehen ihnen trotzdem ich finde es
fahrlässig an der zweite sie sagen sie
wollen kinder ein sozialraum stärken da
ist ja nichts gegen zusagen klappt
brauchen wir mehr jugendclubs mehr
sozialarbeit und sozialraum das ist
völlig richtig aber das kann doch nicht
anstelle von individuellen
rechtsansprüchen treten
das kann doch nicht anstelle von
individuellen hilfen für familien treten
die sie brauchen helft die sie dringend
brauchen wenn eine familie ein
familienhelfer braucht da kann man doch
nicht sagen wir haben da ein
streetworker im jugendclub damit ist die
sache erledigt das kann nicht sein wir
wollen die individuell rechtsansprüche
stärken
wir wollen mehr qualifiziertes personal
in der kinder und jugendhilfe
wir werden ihren gesetzentwurf ablehnen
vielen dank soweit norbert müller von
der fraktion die linke er ist obmann im
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend mit der ankündigung der
ablehnung die linke einen eigenen
gesetzentwurf eingebracht zu diesem
thema nächste rednerin die kinder wie
guss von bündnis 90 die grünen
sprecherin für kinder und
familienpolitik kollegen
in diesem gesetz ist meines erachtens
die zielrichtung gut vieles überfällig
und deshalb werden wir grünen diesem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen und damit möchte
ich auch anfragen
wir haben aber in unserem
entschließungsantrag wesentliche aspekte
noch einmal gewürdigt die wirklich
kurzen beratung beteiligung kinderschutz
prävention inklusion die situation der
pflegekinder das teilen wir das
unterstützen wir dahinter stehen wir
aber es gibt auch unzureichende punkte
und die müssen auch bewohner benannt
werden und das erstaunliche ist ja liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die koalition
weist das selber weil zum ersten mal
erlebe ich dass die koalition selber zum
eigenen gesetz ein entschließungsantrag
schreibt wo noch mal die defizite
aufgezeigt werden das heißt wir glauben
hier selber nicht daran das das was sie
heute hier vorlegen der große aufbruch
ist und das bedaure ich sehr weil das
sollte es nämlich sein
die maschen
die weichen haben sie gestellt aber es
ist die arbeit dass jemand beginnt erst
jetzt und die hausaufgaben werden hier
festgestellt und sie machen politik mit
angezogener handbremse an einer stelle
wo wir eigentlich tatsächlich den signal
auch des gesellschaftlichen aufbruchs
brauchen würden
und ich will das mal ein paar beispielen
vorführen sie erschweren zum beispiel
den ganzen bereich der inklusion weil
sie schon von vornherein einen leistungs
deckel reinschreiben es soll sich was
verändern es soll aber nichts kosten
das funktioniert so leider nicht weil
wenn wir dinge verändern
auch davon ausgehen dass wir manchmal
auch geld dafür ausgeben müssen
mir fehlen noch die experimentierklausel
das kam ja von uns von den grünen als
vorschlag die werden das im bundestag
noch mal bringen weil gerade die
bundesländer die regionen die vor
ausschreiten sollen sollen es auch
machen können nur sowie liegt uns da
auch der wandel beim kinderschutz
verzichten sie auf kooperationen warum
eigentlich danach wird schon länger
gerufen kinderschutz arbeit im
gesundheitsbereich muss auch adäquat
entlohnt finanziert werden damit es
nicht ehrenamtlich ist oder für lauf ist
sondern ein teil des schutzbereichs
misslungen ist ihm komplett der bereich
melde befugnis reform kkg da haben die
experten experten alle gleichermaßen
gerufen und sie waren aber resistent
gegenüber jeglicher form der aufnahme
was uns die expertinnen mit auf dem weg
gegeben haben und bei der kosten
heranziehen bei pflege und heimkindern
da hätte ich mir schon gewünscht dass
sie endlich mal über ihren schatten
rüberspringen warum weil wir damit ein
signal an junge menschen auch setzen
würden euren leistungen anerkannt euren
leistung zählt und wir glauben an euch
wird vertrauen an euch und wenn ihr 300
euro von einem ausbildungs geld verdient
dann solltet ihr das auch verdienen mal
dafür habt ihr auch gearbeitet leistung
muss sich lohnen und das finde ich an
der stände wichtig liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist ein schritt nach vorne
weiter
aber freude es ist der beginn eines
prozesses
und wir stimmen dem zu aber wir werden
auch im bundesrat darauf achten dass es
weitergeht und in den kommenden jahren
sowieso und vielen dank herr präsident
in der letzten sekunde für wunderbare
karte die sie mir gestern zu meinem
geburtstag geschrieben haben
ja so ist das im bundestag da geht es
auch unter politischen gegnern sehr
höflich zu wenn es denn den anlass gibt
ekin deligöz von der fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen als nächstes sie
voraussichtlich vor letzte rednerin zum
kinder und jugend stärken das gesetz und
ricke war von der spd fraktion
danach wird über diesen gesetzentwurf
abgestimmt und er wird hier auch
verabschiedet werden
liebe kollegen und kolleginnen was lange
währt wird endlich gut so hat die ag dok
im letzten herbst ihre stellungnahme zum
neuen kinder und jungs stark uns geht's
überschrieben und heute ist es endlich
soweit
wir beschließen eine reform die über die
gesamte legislaturperiode hinweg
vorbereitet und beraten wurde
staatssekretärin karl marx hat diesen
prozess umsichtig gesteuert und
hartnäckig vorangetrieben
auch frau ministerin ganz herzlichen
dank
und natürlich auch eine
koalitionspartner vereinbar ganz
herzlichen dank für diese verhandlungen
wie sie gelaufen sind auch die
opposition hat sich engagiert mit
eigenen anträgen eingebracht über die
wir heute mit beschließen und aus denen
auch einiges auf seinen weg in das
gesetz gefunden hat und danke auch hier
an die grünen
die hiermit auch schon zustimmung
signalisiert haben aus der fülle der
änderungen möchte ich 3d mir heraus
greifen die mir besonders am herzen
liegen erstens sind da die regelungen zu
nennen die kinder mit psychisch kranken
eltern helfen ganz zum ende der letzten
wahlperiode hatte der bundestag eine
interdisziplinäre ag aus fachleuten
beauftragt empfehlungen an die kinder
und jugendhilfe und an das
gesundheitswesen zur arbeit
seit ende 2009 10 liegt der bericht form
und mit dem teil des gesetzten wir die
darin enthaltenen vorschläge nun um so
erweitern wir den anspruch auf hilfe in
notsituationen wenn zb eltern sich
zeitweilig aufgrund psychischer
erkrankungen oder wegen suchtproblemen
nicht ausreichend um ihre kinder kümmern
können
auf diese hilfen besteht nun ein
rechtsanspruch sie sind aber dennoch
niedrigschwellig ausgestaltet und eine
mögliche einbeziehung von patinnen und
paten in solche hilfen kommt dem wunsch
der betroffenen nach nicht
stigmatisieren den alltags
unterstützungen nach
diese neue hilfe form ist keine
konkurrenz sondern eine ergänzung zu den
hilfen zur erziehung und solle die
erwirkung sorgfältig evaluiert werden
zweitens möchte ich das paket für junge
volljährige nennen
der que river ev hat mir eindrucksvoll
aufgezeigt wie wirksam selbstvertretung
und im parlament sind gut in der
selbstvertretung organisationen nun
einen anspruch auf förderung und
einbeziehung haben und richtig ist es
auch dass junge volljährige eines
soliden rechtsanspruch auf die
fortsetzung von hilfen erhalten
im entschließungsantrag stellen wir klar
dass persönliche lebensumstände die
schulische oder berufliche ausbildung
bei der gewährung von hilfen
berücksichtigt werden müssen
und mit der rückkehr option und der
nachbetreuung wollen wir verhindern dass
junge menschen auf dem weg in die
selbständigkeit scheitern
die stark reduzierte kosten heranziehen
ermöglicht ihnen künftig den aufbau
eines kleinen finanziellen polsters und
das wissenschaftliche projekt kreatives
statistik für dafür ende 2020 mittel
bereitgestellt haben wird in den
kommenden jahren weitere argumente für
eine gute und nachhaltige ausgestaltung
von hilfen beisteuern da bin ich davon
überzeugt und schließlich und
schließlich drittens möchte ich das
größte projekt dieser reformen mit
hilfen aus einer hand haben
endlich einen fahrplan hin zur
zusammenführung von eingliederungs und
jugendhilfe geschaffen
sie sind ein klarer handlungsauftrag und
ein versprechen und nach der reform ist
vor der reform und wir werden sofort
damit beginnen
kommunen können verfahrens lotsen
freiwillig schon vor 20 24 einsätzen
wir begleiten die modellprojekte sind
die bmw führt ab sofort mittel
bereitgestellt und in einem weiteren
beteiligungsprozess gibt es dann viel zu
regeln das ziel ist klar alle familien
in denen kinder mit behinderungen leben
dürfen nicht nur nicht schlechter
gestellt werden sondern wir sind besser
schneller und unbürokratischer zu ihren
hilfen kommen die träger wünschen und
das zu recht ein modernes leistungsrecht
gute arbeit zur bindung von fachkräften
und mit tarif schutz
darum wird uns das achte
sozialgesetzbuch auch in den kommenden
legislaturperiode weiterhin beschäftigen
und hier sind wir alle in der
verantwortung ich freue mich darauf und
werde heute um ihre zustimmung danke
so hat unmittelbar von der spd es kommt
jetzt die phrase sich letzte rednerin
nadine schön
der vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sie dort im
fraktionsvorstand für die bereiche
zuständig um die es hier geht beim
kinder- jugend- und stadt kinder und
jugend stärkung gesetz nadine schön von
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wie schade dass
dieses gesetz bisher in der
öffentlichkeit nicht mehr aufmerksamkeit
erfahren hat denn mit dieser reform
heute verändern dir das leben von vielen
vielen kindern und jugendlichen in
unserem land und deshalb war es auch so
wichtig dass wir uns ganz intensiv mit
diesem gesetz beschäftigt haben in
meiner letzten rede hatte ich mich
bereits beim ministerium bedankt dass
den von uns ein geforderten
ausführlichen prozess auch wirklich gut
umgesetzt hat aber auch die im parlament
haben wochenlang in vielen gesprächen
anhörungen berichterstatter gesprächen
und natürlich auch in gesprächen vor ort
uns intensiv mit der nicht ganz und
komplexen materie auseinandergesetzt und
ich finde das ergebnis kann sich
wirklich sehen lassen und deshalb zwei
worte an die vorräten kollegin müller
wenn der asc in berlin schlecht
ausgestattet dann liegt die
verantwortung in berlin und nicht bei
uns im bundestag und deshalb empfehle
ich dass sie sich bei ihren kollegen
dafür einsetzen dass auch dort der asd
besser ausgesetzt wird ausgestattet wird
und ihnen sagen sie dass es in allen
ländern so aber in berlin ist das
besonders schlecht mit wem an diesem
morgen viele bilder da steht koch viele
begegnungen der letzten jahre immer
wieder wo ich festgestellt habe
da haben wir probleme im system der
jugendhilfe da passt das nicht zusammen
da gibt es schnittstellen die besser
aufeinander abgestimmt sein müssten nun
ich bin wirklich stolz dass wir heute
mit diesem gesetz viele dieser probleme
lösen
da ist zum beispiel das projekt oase aus
meiner heimat aus sankt wendel ein
projekt der caritas dieses projekt
kümmert sich seit jahren und kinder
psychisch kranker eltern und bisher lief
das anders ehrenamtlich spenden durch
sehr viel aufwand wurde eine struktur
aufgebaut wo man gerade diese kinder
unterstützt denn die eltern sind in
behandlung psychologischer behandlung
oder auch in ärztlicher behandlung aber
die kinder die falten und durch das
raster des trust ab bisher
sie stellen sich die frage warum steht
da papa morgens nicht auf warum ist die
mama so aggressiv wartung wie ist das
mit dem alkohol warum sind die so
komisch und was hat das mit mir zu tun
bin ich vielleicht selbst schuld und
diesen kinder zu helfen in
gesprächsangebote zu machen ihnen
gruppenangebote zu machen wo sie sich
austauschen können
auch ein setting zu haben wo die erste
sich miteinander unterhalten können das
gab es bisher nicht und das musste alles
ehrenamtlich gestemmt werden
wir haben uns als unions fraktion dafür
eingesetzt und da will ich an vorderster
front marcus weinberg und paul edita
nennen die mit zusammen mit den
familienpolitiker dies im prozess in der
letzten legislaturperiode gestartet
haben auch aus solchen erfahrungen die
ist sie bei mir vor ort gemacht habe und
heute haben wir die lösung heute bieten
wir gerade für diese zielgruppe eine
passgenaue lösung mit unterstützung
beraten ehrenamtlichen angeboten lotsen
und das wird gerade für diese kinder
ganz viel ändern
ich denke an die vielen gespräche mit
den pflegeeltern die finde ich einen
wahnsinnigen tolle aufgabe erfüllen
nämlich kindern eine heimat zu geben und
sie sagen wir machen das gerne wir
machen das mit herzblut wir geben da
sehr viel zeit liebe rein in diese in
diese familien in diese kinder aber wir
haben auch echt probleme wir leben in
einem permanenten zustand der
unsicherheit wir haben oft zu wenig
unterstützung das jugendamt wir hängen
in der luft sind kinder erwachsen werden
dann gibt es einen haken das wollen wir
eigentlich nicht wir wollen sie
begleiten ins erwachsenenleben die sie
wirklich selbstständig sind und auch
hier setzen wir an mit diesem gesetz wir
nehmen die care lieber in den blick und
ermöglichen angebote auch über die
volljährigkeit hinaus wir schaffen es
dass diese familien besser unterstützt
werden und die kinder werden in zukunft
nicht mehr 75 prozent ihres einkommens
abgeben müssen sondern sie werden 75
prozent des behalten können und für den
ferienjob und die ehrenamtliche arbeit
des konzertes behalten und das ist auch
gut so wir nehmen die familien in den
blick wo die kinder in heimen oder in
der pflegefamilie sind aber wo
eigentlich eine gute emotionale bin
der eltern zu diesen kindern da ist und
die oft sagen ich werde ja viel zu wenig
unterstützt
künftig können diese eltern auf hilfen
zur erziehung bekommen wenn die kinder
fremd untergebracht sind und dass das
wichtig denn viele kinder wollen noch
mal zurück zu ihren leiblichen eltern
und viele leibliche eltern wollen die
kinder auch wieder zurückholen und suche
nach unterstützung nachhilfe um ihre
erziehungskompetenz zu stärken und auch
das ermöglichen wir mit diesem gesetz
die behinderten kinder nehmen wir in den
blick mit der inklusion trieben lösung
wir stärken die beteiligung und mein
herzensthema beim sexuellen missbrauch
schaffen wir es dass künftig der
austausch zwischen den ganzen
fachkräften zwischen ärzten und dem
jugendamt auch besser werden soll
damit kinder ganzheitlich in den blick
genommen werden und damit wir missbrauch
und gewalt vorbeugen können ob das ein
meilenstein und deshalb herzlichen dank
für dieses gute so weidner die schönen
letzten geräten und jetzt wird über
diese gesetzentwurf kinder und jugend
stärkung des gesetzes stehen den
bundestag
der kommt von den regierungsfraktionen
es gibt einen gegenentwurf der
linksfraktion und sieben anträge der
oppositionspartei insgesamt zum
gesetzentwurf fiel unter buchstabe
müssen die empfehlungen auf drucksache
872 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf den drucksachen 26
107 und 27 481 in der ausschuss fassung
anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen das handzeichen
die koaltion fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen wer stimmt dagegen die fdp und
die linke enthält sich die fdp dann ist
der gesetzentwurf mit den genannten
mehrheiten angenommen dritte beratungen
zur abstimmung ich bitte diejenigen die
die mit entwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
da angesehen
es stimmt dagegen da eigentlich selber
enthält sich daran wie sehr dieser
gesetzentwurf mit den gleichen
mehrheiten in der zweiten lesung
angenommen unter buchstabe b sagen wir
sind weniger auf drucksache 28 870
empfiehlt der ausschuss eine
entschließung anzunehmen
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
daran gesehen
die koalitionsfraktionen ist ihm dagegen
während sich dann ist die see bist du es
empörung bei enthaltung der fdp und
gegen die stimmen der übrigen
oppositionsfraktion mit den stimmen der
koalition angenommen und damit kommen
wir nun zu den erstanträgen wir beginnen
mit der ab 7 über die vier
entschließungsanträge der fraktion der
fdp entschließungsantrag auf drucksache
28 8 779 wer stimmt dafür die fdp
bündnis 90 die grünen die linke ist
dagegen
die koalition und die afg die
entschieden die entschließung sagen wir
gestrafft gelähmt entschließungsantrag
auf druck seiner 28 8 80 wird stimmt
dafür die fdp bündnis die grünen sind
dagegen
die koalition die fdp enthielt sich die
linke wie hat den bündnisgrünen abstimmt
wir haben dafür gestimmt also gut gegen
die stimmen von fdp bundesrat die grünen
bei enthaltung der linken nicht der
beschlussempfehlung mit den stimmen der
übrigen fraktionen der
entschließungsantrag mit den übrigen
fraktionen abgelehnt
entschließungsantrag auf drucksache 28 8
61 mehr stimmt dafür die fdp bündnis 90
die grünen sind dagegen
koalition und asd
sie enthält sich die linke die
entschließungsantrag ist abgelehnt
entschließungsantrag auf 8 drucksache 28
8 82
wer stimmt dafür fdp bündnis 90 die
grünen das sind dagegen koalition und
afd
die linke enthält sich der
entschließungsantrag es abgelehnt
abstimmung über den entschließungsantrag
der fraktion die linke auf der
drucksache 28 8 83 wer stimmt dafür die
linke stimmte dagegen
die übrigen fraktionen der
entschließungsantrag es abgelehnt
dann stimmen wir über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen
bündnis wollen die grünen auf der
drucksache 28 8 84 ab das sind dafür
bündnis 90 die grünen und die fdp was
sind dagegen
wer enthält sich bei enthaltung der
fraktion die linke ist der
entschließungsantrag mit den stimmen der
kollegen mit den gegen die stimmen durch
der entschließungsantrag mit den stimmen
der koalition der fdp abgelehnt
das ist das schicksal allen situationen
da geht es um schulsozialarbeit gehen
oder jugend reform hilfe über neue
perspektive für straßenkinder oder auch
mehrfach den kitas der ausschuss
empfiehlt oder buchstabe c seiner
bestimmt sie wählen die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion der fdp auf der
drucksache 26 158 mit dem titel § 94
absatz 6 des achten buch
sozialgesetzbuch abschaffen bessere
chancen auf ein selbstbestimmtes leben
auch für pflegekinder
wer stimmt für die beschlussempfehlung
die koalition wer stimmt dagegen
hf die fdp die linke enthält sich die
beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen unter
buchstabe d empfiehlt der ausschuss die
ablehnung des antrags der fraktion die
linke auf der drucksache 64 21
mit dem titel mehr fachkräfte für gute
kitas und eine starke kinder und
jugendliche mehr stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung die koalition die
fdp steht dagegen die linke enthielt
sich die fdp bündnis 90 grünen sind
weder bus angenommen und heißt in jedem
fall ist ja dass die anträge der
oppositionsfraktionen abgelegt werden es
handelt sich um eine beschlussempfehlung
das ist auch schon das zuständige
gesetzbuch aufhebung des kostenbeitrag
junger menschen in stationären kinder
und jugendhilfeeinrichtungen der
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend empfiehlt und der buchstabe a
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache 20 127 den gesetzentwurf der
fraktion die linke auf drucksache 17 0
91 abzulehnen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um das
land zeigen dass die linke und die fdp
das stimmt dagegen die koalition mehr
enthält sich der hfc bündnis 90 grünen
gesetzentwurf in zweiter beratung
abgelehnt also ein gesetzentwurf der
fraktion die linke ladung
tagesordnungspunkt 11 d in der fraktion
l mit überweisung der vorlage auf der
drucksache 28 7 69 an den ausschuss für
familie senioren frauen und jugend
vorgeschlagen gibt's weitere
überweisungs vorschläge das nicht der
fall dann verfahren wir vorgeschlagen
tagesordnungspunkt 11 e bis m fähiges
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend zu dem antrag der fraktion
die linke mit dem titel
schulsozialarbeit für alle schülerinnen
und schüler sichern
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
24 7 26
den antrag der fraktion die linke auf
der drucksache
9000 53 abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
mission es empfehlungen
die koalitionsfraktionen und die afd
das stimmt dagegen die linke und bündnis
90/die grünen er enthält sich die die
fdp damit ist die bistums empfehlung
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 11 f
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
familie senioren frauen und jugend zu
dem anderen der fraktion die linke mit
dem titel kinder und jugendhilfe reform
vom kopf auf die füße stellen die aus
dem viele teile deswegen auf der druck
sei 26 5 53 den antrag der fraktion die
linke auf drucksachen 7909 abzulehnen
wer stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlungen die koalition wäre
stimmt dagegen kurs fraktion und fdp
stimmen für die beschlussempfehlung das
stimmt dagegen die linke bündnis wollen
sie die wohl auch enthält sich während
hält sich bündnis wollen die grünen und
die fdp die mit uns entscheidung ist
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 11 g kinder bergungs
gesetz verabschieden es ist ja schon
daran kein zweifel ist beschlossen